For the medical examination for the study permit in Canada.
I uh I have I had my medical examination at the bedside,
so in my country so basically I am on the spot,
they took my blood.
Uh they did the test uh Of HIV they did U Recreation uh it's to control,
I think,
the functioning of the kidneys.
Then they did the X-ray,
the X-ray lung forgiveness to see if I had TB,
they also analyzed my urine to see if there were
any and everything So other than that,
they took my blood pressure,
they examined me,
they asked me a lot of questions,
was I?
I've had contact with people who have Y'a contact with people who have TB,
or if I have a particular illness or if I take particular
medications et cetera So uh,
that was basically it And after the visit I think 48 hours later they
sent me the results So uh Well everything was normal and that's it So
that's what to expect And that's it.